er würde wahrscheinlich auch sagen
sollen was man lieber nicht höchsten
doch der grund dafür täglich also
wahrscheinlich denkt
in schwerelosigkeit durchs weltall zu
schweben muss sich ziemlich cool als
ziemlich cool auf schwerelosigkeit macht
manche sachen aber ein bisschen
schwierig unter anderem so einfache
sachen die essen trinken oder sich
einfach mal kurz hinlegen eine sache
besonders unangenehm und zwar mit
astronauten im weltraum auch nicht sie
können schon aber sie also nicht mehr
gefällt ist dass er nicht immer auf
sondern wegen der fehlenden schwerkraft
auf der erde wird das was wir essen in
unserem magen aufgetrennt in feste
flüssige und gasförmige dank der
kombination festes ein flüssiges sind
nach unten gase steigen nach oben und
können dann durch münster in die
freiheit entlassen in schwerelosigkeit
gibt es keine trennung zwischen nun fest
flüssig und gasförmig sondern es ist
alles nur ein einziger tragen das heißt
aller surfer nicht rücken
ohne direkt zu kaufen deswegen keine
cola für astronauten das gute ist dass
man sich im weltraum nicht so ohne
weiteres vollkosten kann beim kurz wie
so ein blog fürchte ich werde sich keine
schwere hürde in seide man hat einen
helm auf das wären etwas weniger
deswegen mit astronauten geraten
möglichst nicht zurück man sollte
überhaupt seine frustrationen im
weltraum möglichst gering halten denn
was in der schwerelosigkeit aus oder
weitere weg ist meine tränen
nämlich nicht einfach die bank
unterlassen sondern auch die zwei blocks
an den augen hängen bleiben
expertentipp solltet ihr euch jemals in
der schwerelosigkeit wiederfinden muss
dringend rücken könnte versuchen eine
künstliche gravitation herzustellen die
den ihr euch kräftig wohl der wand
abschluss und gleichzeitig rips
eigentlich müsste man sich ja von unten
abstoßen weil sonst würde man die
künstliche schwerkraft in die andere
richtung und dann wäre alles noch viel
schlimmer
ich bin niemals das ist der neue kanal
schön schlauch jeden donnerstag gibt es
ab jetzt hier lustiges nützlich ist oder
ob manchmal auch völlig unnützes wissen
wissenschaftlich erklärt wenn ihr dabei
sein wollt dann freue ich mich wenn ihr
uns abonniert dann sehen uns nämlich
nicht am donnerstag wieder